now I know what you're thinking hang on
the Soviet Union had elections but
wasn't it a one-party state well yes but
that didn't mean that you couldn't vote
and the USSR had many elections open to
the wider Soviet public now the nature
of these votes did change over the
decades and as such we're going to focus
on the years when the USSR was run by
Joseph Stalin since he's not really one
you would associate with democracy so
citizens of the USSR elected
representatives to the Supreme Soviet
the legislative arm of the government
and these elections were held every four
years and the process for these
elections was fairly simple for citizens
when polling day arrived they would go
to their local polling station and they
would receive their ballot which would
only have one candidate on it so most
people the fact that you could only pick
from one Communist Party approved
candidate doesn't seem very democratic
and that's because it isn't however
these elections weren't without their
purpose and in some ways it did give
ordinary Soviet citizens a voice in how
the USSR was run before that it's
important to say how candidates were
selected and what this meant for how the
USSR operated after these elections
obviously you couldn't get onto the
ballot without the express consent of
the Communist Party and the vast
majority of candidates were Communist
Party ones some were independent
candidates which gives a nice bit of
variation providing you ignore the fact
that they were also communists and would
agree with the Communist Party on
everything also in case you're wondering
the reason why all candidates stood
unopposed was that the party wouldn't
allow itself to appear divided and just
so you know here's how the voting
process would work one you'd turn up at
the polling station two you'd receive a
ballot that would have the name of your
candidate on it three you'd place their
ballot in the ballot box and that would
be counted as a vote for the candidate
but what if a person didn't wish to vote
for the candidate on the paper well then
they were free to enter the voting booth
and scribble out the candidates name but
then everyone would know that you did it
because you were one of the few that
kept their ballot a secret so with
elections being run in this way then
surely there was no point of them will
actually know for the state they were
used to demonstrate popular support for
the Communist Party in its policies high
turnout meant that it was widely popular
which you could use to then demonstrate
to the rest of the world that I had
popular support this is why the
government went to such lengths to get
people to vote and if he were on weld
they'd bring the ballot box to you so
how did these elections benefit ordinary
people well here's the thing communist
candidates could fail to be elected
despite it being a one horse race you
see if a candidate failed to get 50% of
their areas vote be that from spoiled
ballots or low turnout then they weren't
elected and
a new candidate was brought forward
knowing this Soviet citizens would often
band together and make petitions for
local changes and if they weren't met no
one went out to vote thus if said
representative wanted to keep their nice
political job they had to do something
so in essence Soviet democracy wasn't
really a democracy but it would be wrong
to say that these elections were nothing
more than a farce in a waste of time
Soviet citizens were smart about using
them to get local improvements that they
needed it may not have been particularly
democratic since you couldn't vote the
Communist Party out of office but it did
in a very small sense give you an input
into how things were run I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching but thanks to my patreon
supporters whom you can see on screen
now plus with an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette Danny Maloney coolin
Castleman party-boy Co Rob Waterhouse Mo
Aaron the white Michael Reynolds Chris
wicker Gustav Swan Ashwin Emperor Gareth
Turner David Silverman spinning three
plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check a
Spencer Lightfoot
Winston k-word Anthony Beckett Kelly
moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Lexi Schwinn Skye Chappell
and Ike